[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the langfocus
channel and my name is paul today's
topic is the greek language or elinica
as it's called in greek the word greek
is a word that instantly brings to mind
images of ancient civilizations and
culture it may not be the most widely
spoken language in the world today but
it did play an extremely influential
role in the development of other
european languages and in european
culture in general today it's spoken by
more than 13 million native speakers
mainly in greece where it's the only
official language and is spoken by 11
million people the republic of cyprus
where it's spoken by around 975 000
people and by minorities in parts of
albania italy and turkey as well as by
greek immigrants living all around the
world
whether you realize it or not if you
know english you know some greek around
six percent of the vocabulary of english
is of greek origin and some estimates
reach as high as 12 to 15 percent
and if we look specifically at the
sciences and technology the proportion
of greek words and roots skyrockets
dramatically when you mention the
encyclopedia or when you talk about
physics class or when you ask for the
butter you're using words that developed
from greek
history greek is a member of the
hellenic branch of the indo-european
language family some consider hellenic
to be a single language branch
consisting of only greek while others
consider some varieties of modern greek
to be closely related but separate
languages the development of greek can
be broken down into a number of stages
proto-greek proto-greek or
proto-hellenic developed from
proto-indo-european and was probably
spoken in the 3rd millennium bce over 4
000 years ago as hellenic people
migrated into the balkan peninsula or
maybe even earlier depending on where
and when proto-indo-european originated
mycenaean greek mycenean greek is the
form of greek that developed in
mycenaean greece in the second
millennium bce when the greek mainland's
first advanced civilization arose the
earliest known greek text comes from
this period dating back to around 1400
bce it's a clay tablet written in a
writing system called linear b not the
system that we know today as the greek
alphabet
the existence of such tablets makes
greek the oldest recorded living
language to be clear there are older
texts written in other languages like
sumerian egyptian hieroglyphics and
acadian but those are all dead languages
while greek has lived on until today
sometime toward the end of the mycenaean
greek stage or in the early part of the
ancient greek stage the greek alphabet
was adopted the date of adoption is
around 1100 bce plus or minus a couple
hundred years we're not quite sure the
greek alphabet was derived from the
phoenician alphabet with greek adopting
and modifying the phoenician letters and
generally keeping similar sounds for
each one there are also several unique
greek letters that did not derive from
phoenician you may notice that some of
the symbols are reversed that might be
explained by the fact that phoenician
was written from right to left while
greek is written from left to right
at first there were numerous local
varieties of the greek alphabet but the
standard 24-letter greek alphabet became
widespread throughout the greek speaking
world during the 4th century bce in
cyprus a different script called the
cypriotic syllabary was used between the
11th and 4th centuries bce when the
greek alphabet was finally adopted the
greek alphabet would eventually give
rise to numerous other alphabets
including the latin alphabet the coptic
alphabet the cyrillic alphabet and the
gothic alphabet ancient greek the
adoption of the greek alphabet took
place around the beginning of the
ancient greek stage of the language
which lasted from about the 9th century
bce until the 4th century bce this stage
of the language corresponds to the
archaic and classical periods of greek
history
the oldest existing greek literature and
indeed some of the oldest western
literature dates from this period
including the two epic poems the iliad
and the odyssey which are attributed to
homer there were various dialects of
ancient greek at the time including
attic the dialect of athens as well as
ionic these epic poems were written in
homeric greek a literary form of the
language based on the ionic dialect of
greek with elements of some other
dialects
during the classical period of greek
history more texts of tremendous
importance to western civilization were
written in ancient greek including the
works of socrates plato and aristotle
and many texts of foundational
importance in logic math and science
koine greek with the conquests of
alexander the great in the 4th century
bce the greek language became widespread
in a form known as koine greek koine
meaning common
it was based mainly on the attic and
ionic dialects with some elements of
others as well and it served as a lingua
franca throughout the conquered regions
it was spoken most widely in the eastern
mediterranean region
a large amount of important literature
was written in koine greek including the
new testament and the septuagint a greek
translation of the old testament coina
greek remained the lingua franca of the
eastern mediterranean region during the
roman empire and became the official
language of the byzantine empire until
the 15th century medieval greek
medieval greek also known as byzantine
greek developed from koine greek during
the byzantine empire during this period
the spoken language based on koine greek
began to develop towards modern greek
while written greek tended to be more
conservative and similar to ancient
greek
modern greek the end of the byzantine
empire marks the beginning of the modern
greek period during the modern greek
period two forms of greek arose the
first was demotic or zimotiki which
means by the people this is the modern
spoken form of the greek language the
second was
a literary form of greek with features
of both demonic greek and ancient greek
this resulted in a state of diglossia
with the spoken language and the formal
written language being significantly
different until the adoption of demotic
as the official language of greece in
1976
that form of demotic is referred to as
standard modern greek there are several
dialects of modern greek as well
northern dialects ionian peloponnesian
dialects southern dialects
old athenian and there's also the
cypriot dialect spoken on the island of
cyprus
with one exception the endangered
zarconian dialect all forms of modern
greek developed from koine greek despite
its long history and its different
stages of development the greek language
has changed relatively little compared
to other languages during the same time
frame my understanding is that speakers
of modern greek can look at an ancient
greek text and recognize a lot of
familiar vocabulary a lot of familiar
words even if they can't make sense of
the sentence itself this relative lack
of change in the language is probably
the result of ancient greek's continued
influence on written greek throughout
the centuries so what is greek like
let's examine some of the features of
greek specifically modern greek syntax
there's disagreement over whether
greek's default word order is svo or vso
but the most common word order is svo
look at this sentence here emis
this sentence means we speak greek
here's the subject the verb and the
object but in greek the subject pronoun
is not always necessary
[Music]
the subject pronoun isn't necessary here
because we know from the verb
conjugation that this is the first
person plural so the subject pronoun is
typically used when you want to draw
attention to it or make it the topic of
the sentence despite svo being the most
common word order in greek the words can
actually be arranged in different ways
usually to put focus on one element of
the sentence
here's a sentence that means yanis loves
maria oyanis
this sentence here is svo and notice
that the definite article comes before
proper names
this time it's ovs
this time it's sov
this time it's osv
these three word orders here are all
ways of drawing focus to the object of
the sentence it's possible to change the
order of the words like this because
grammatical case inflections tell us the
noun's function even if it's in a
different location
there are four grammatical cases in
greek nominative genitive accusative and
vocative in sentences like these with
proper names the names themselves don't
have case inflections but the definite
articles do notice that the two definite
articles are different we'll come back
to that in a minute let's look at
another sentence and see the noun's case
inflection
this sentence means i lost my new
glasses word for word it's lost
i which we know from the inflection the
new
glasses my
this word
which means glasses is an inflected form
of the neuter noun
which means glass it's the nominative
accusative and vocative plural form yes
it can be all three of those
also the definite article is inflected
to agree with the noun this is the
neuter nominative accusative plural form
of the definite article as you can see
there are several other forms of the
definite article too let's go back to an
earlier sentence for a second this
definite article here before yanis is in
the masculine singular nominative form
and this definite article here before
maria is in the feminine singular
accusative form even when the word order
changed the definite articles stayed the
same allowing us to know which person
was the subject the nominative case and
which one was the object the accusative
case
also the adjective is inflected to agree
with the noun this is the neuter
nominative accusative vocative plural
form
now let's change the noun in the
sentence and see what happens
this means i lost my new dog this time
the noun is inflected to show the
masculine singular accusative form the
definite article is also in the
masculine singular accusative form and
so is the adjective the main thing i
want you to notice here is that the noun
but also the words that come together
with the noun like the definite article
and the adjective change form to show
case but also gender and number verbs
greek verbs have two different stems two
different forms one to show perfect mood
which means an action is complete and
one to show imperfect mood which means
an action is incomplete then various
affixes particles and auxiliary verbs
are added to these two stems to show
past tense and non-past tense let's
examine the verb meaning to help this is
the perfect stem showing completed
action voiciso and this is the imperfect
stem
voil now let's look at how to create
some verb tenses based on these stems
here's the present tense
this means i am helping my friend and
this could also mean i help my friend in
a general sense the present tense form
is based on the imperfect stem because
the action is not complete yet it's
happening now here's the imperfect tense
this means i was helping my friend or i
used to help my friend again this form
is based on the imperfect stem because
the action was continuing at a certain
point in the past
now here's the simple past
this means i helped my friend the simple
past is based on the perfect verb stem
because the action is complete future
this means i will help my friend the
simple future tense is also based on the
perfect stem because it's an action with
a start and a finish it's not a
continuing action
and the present perfect
this means i have helped my friend many
times
the present perfect is also based on the
perfect stem as you might have guessed
from its name because the action has
been done at some point in the past
also notice the auxiliary verb which is
the first person singular form of the
verb meaning to have
let's look at one final greek sentence
and see what we discovered
this sentence means we fell in love and
got married immediately word for word
it's we fall in love past tense first
person plural inflection and get married
past tense first person plural
immediately
this verb
means to fall in love this verb
means to get married this ending is the
first person plural past tense
conjugation this piece here shows past
tense and this piece shows number and
person
these two verbs are not active verbs but
rather medio-passive verbs you might see
the word passive there and think that
these are passive verbs but
medio-passive verbs are not always
passive they might also be intransitive
or reflexive or reciprocal in this case
they seem to be reciprocal meaning that
both people are doing the action to each
other or with each other
this ending here on the dictionary form
of the verb is a hint that it's a
medio-passive verb one of the main
things you may have noticed about greek
is that it's a highly inflected language
with lots of different word forms and
lots of different endings that can
attach to nouns and to verb stems and
that might seem kind of intimidating but
there are lots of languages out there
that are much more inflected than greek
so please don't be scared of that the
story of the greek language is a very
long and spectacular one and there's so
much to say about greek that we can't
fit into this video but hopefully you
were a little bit inspired to learn more
about greek one of the oldest languages
in the world and a language that has
influenced many other languages and the
very foundations of western civilization
and thought okay the question of the day
to native speakers of greek how well can
you understand written greek from the
past like koine greek and ancient greek
and to people who have studied greek
what did you find challenging and not so
challenging about greek be sure to
follow langfocus on facebook twitter and
instagram and as always i would like to
say thank you to all of my wonderful
patreon supporters especially these
people right here on the screen for
their monthly pledges thank you for
watching and have a nice day
[Music]
you